time for this week's pet project lori
here and joins us from the nspca
trot along someone who needs a good safe
home and this
is sarah smores yes it is a cutie
beautiful
five and a half year old female cat he's
a beautiful black tandy cat you can see
here and she is great with
families and kids and dogs and cats we
think although
we do advise that she is with mature
children
because she is a little arthritic so she
takes supplements for her arthritis for
that
but she's uh very vocal so if you
um want a cat that's gonna talk to you
sarah is your girl
he's also a lap cat so if you're looking
for somebody to
watch tv with during the pandemic
there is going to be a great companion
for that and you know kendall the cats
aren't always
well behaved when we make our television
appearances
but you can see what a good girl she's
beginning
that i know would be a great companion
for someone who's watching you today
is made for this moment right she was
ready for her close-up
so she's not great with kids necessarily
what about other
animals um we just think that because of
our arthritis
we just need to make sure it's a little
older kid so that they're aware that
that they don't manhandle her too much
although the supplements are going to
help a lot with the arthritis
as always you invite people to make an
appointment they can come down there and
spend time with sarah smores
and all the other animals up for
adoption absolutely
just go to nevadaspca.org and make an
adoption appointment and our
fantastic team here and adoption
counselors will
tell you more about her and how she can
join your family
sarah smores is officially a star now
thanks laurie
yes thanks kendall if you're interested
in adopting a pet go to nevadaspca.org
or you can call them at that phone
number 702-873-7722